flugchaos so haben es alle erwartet ab
heute und unsere reporter schicken uns
jetzt gerade diese bilder hier flughafen
düsseldorf sie sehen es lange schlangen
die längste schlange aktuell viele
hundert rund 400 meter lang heißt es von
unseren reportern
es ist jetzt schon chaos und dabei kommt
der große ansturm erst ab dem nachmittag
ja da will man wirklich nicht drin
stehen wir zeigen ihnen hier den ganzen
tag bei bild live die langen die
längsten die frustrierenden flughafen
schlangen denn heute ist der tag an dem
er für millionen deutsche schon die
sommerferien beginnen für alle nordrhein
westfalen und gleich ist schulschluss
schön urlaub würden wir gerne sagen
können kann aber nicht ja denn der
urlaub wird sehr viele erstmal ja nicht
besonders gut beginnen leider flugchaos
heute ist eben tag eins von diesen
großen flugchaos tag das ist ihr urlaubs
frust
ich finde es unverschämt
die organisation deutsch stimmt doch von
hinten das ist extrem ärgerlich unser
flieger geht erst um 10 42 aber wenn wir
jetzt mal ein bisschen später kommen
würden doch das wäre eine katastrophe
aber da macht es auch keinen spaß aber
der flieger denke ich mal wartet nicht
auf uns gleich ne aus insofern es ist
schon sehr ärgerlich aber die schlange
ist ellenlang und natürlich hektik kommt
dann irgendwann auch nur weil die leute
angst haben dass sie ein flieger
verpassen nur zwei schalter offen für
tausende von menschen das ist einfach
nur super nervig ist vor einem geraden
mit kleinem kind das man hier so lange
stehen muss es keine family line obwohl
wir nach vorne geschickt worden jetzt
muss man es wieder hinten anstellen und
es gibt überhaupt kein verständnis
dass man hier zwei stunden zwei
kilometer ja fast vor der abfertigung
vor der eigentlich schon steht
finde ich doch ziemlich verwunderlich
also da gibt es ja wohl ganz
offensichtlich ein großes
personalproblem im hintergrund was man
nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann da ist
der sicherheitsbereich immer seine zeit
braucht dafür kommt man ja auch zwei
stunden vorher ich war heute sogar drei
stunden hier bleibt aber so langsam ein
bisschen nervös und weiß nicht ob ich
diese diese ganze schlange hier schaffen
kann bevor es dann sonst einchecken geht
und kopf von 0 dass ich irgendwie wir
wegkommen
das ist so ein stress und das zum
sommerferien starts in nrw und der grund
sind entschuldigung ist redet sie uns
hier gerade diese sie einmal dazwischen
und der grund sind streiks vor allem auf
dem weg nach mallorca denn auch noch die
lufthansa die nochmal 2000 flügel
streicht das kommt also auch noch oben
drauf und sie sehen es auch noch chaos
an den flughäfen also dann wenn sie noch
nicht mal im flieger weil vor allen
dingen personal fehlt das ist das
hauptproblem im moment am check in bei
der gepäckabfertigung beim gepäck
wiederholen an den bändern also alles
nicht so wie es sein sollte ausgerechnet
zum großen ferien statt was ist da
schiefgelaufen wer hat da eigentlich
schuld daran wenn ihr lange geplanter
verdienter urlaub jetzt kaputt geht und
wo es war ein chaos hier kriegen sie
live heute und an den nächsten tagen in
den nächsten wochen alle infos zum flug
chaos wir haben sozusagen flugchaos
lagezentrum eingerichtet mit allen live
der daten von den flughäfen damit auch
sie ganz genau wissen wo geht was und wo
geht gar nichts mehr und wir sind
natürlich mit unseren reportern draußen
an den flughäfen michael engelberg ist
am flughafen in düsseldorf und janine
wollbrett am flughafen frankfurt schönen
guten tag ich beiden jeannin die lage
ist wirklich wirklich stressig für viele
die jetzt endlich in die ferien wollen
sie sich diese ferien wohl verdient
haben und jetzt stehen sie dort am
größten stress erzählt uns einmal was
spielt sich da genau ab
ja also jetzt ist gerade bei uns bist
eine flaute ruhe vor dem nächsten sturm
nicht mal an denn als heute morgen hier
waren 36 also bis von einer halben
stunde war hier alles vollversion des
spaßes habe mal die schlagen hier
abgegangen das waren über 400 metern
habe ich aufgehört zu zählen die sind
natürlich sehr sauer die reisende weil
es einfach sagen es gibt es nicht also
dass man jetzt noch noch eine stunde
früher da sein muss damit den flieger
noch erwischt weil einfach zu wenig
personal da ist an der abfertigung und
und runter und wir haben natürlich auch
mit reisen gesprochen haben sie gefragt
weil hier in frankfurt und münchen ist
das drehkreuz vor über die sommerferien
diese 2020 flüge streichen möchte und da
ist auch ein richtiger 10 schon fast
dabei die leute sagen gerade lufthansa
eine weltfirma die flüge sind sehr teuer
und dann kriegen sie sich geregelt
jahrhundert sei nicht erst seit gestern
und david der flug einfach gestrichen
also ziemlich unmut er unmut am
frankfurter flughafen weiter nach
düsseldorf paprika als grad schon gesagt
nrw heute ist der ferienstadt millionen
wollen endlich wieder richtig in den
urlaub fliegen michael engelberg dort in
düsseldorf und da auch schon stress wie
viel meter haben bei euch die schlangen
und vor allen dingen gibt auch da die
stimmung schon jetzt in den
morgenstunden vormittagsstunden
ja hallo also die stimmung die könnte
tatsächlich kippen also das eigentlich
ist ja dass hier wirklich die schlangen
sehr sehr groß sind hier auf der rechten
seite in der mitte da ist der flieger
nach forte ventura und wenn man sich
umguckt hier sind ganz ganz viele
schlangen hier werden teilweise leute
schnell abgefertigt andere gar nicht der
flieger nach alicante der geht um nach
zwölf und jetzt herr t bis w wie wissen
ich habe nicht versprochen der medizin
ist schon sehr früh da hat aber lust auf
urlaub aber ist aufgrund der tatsache
dass hier nicht so richtig was vorwärts
geht früh gekommen genau die
berichterstattung war schon so dass man
ein bisschen zeit mitbringen sollte und
da sind zwei stunden früher gestartet
jetzt um uns einzustellen
aber man muss ja auch sagen viel das ist
ja auch corona geschuldet personal ist
einfach nicht da und da muss man halt
auch mal ein bisschen zeit mitbringen
wer zwei jahre liegt wenn wir jetzt noch
hier eine nacht verbringen müssten aber
ich hoffe wir sind früher noch los um
dann pünktlich zu starten wann geht der
flieger bei unserer flieger geht um 10
41 also 250
und boarding ist 15 oder so mal vor dem
tor aber da haben sind tatsächlich schon
eine ziemlich lange zeit einkalkuliert
na ja auf jeden fall klar muss man muss
man ja auch die berichterstattung ist so
und die leute tun auch nur ihr
möglichstes hier glaube ich das ist
einfach den geschuldet dass durch corona
viel personal verloren gegangenes
tauchen und die kriegt man nicht so
schnell wieder was ist denn wenn ich
jetzt für sie nicht reichen sollte
klar der erde steigt aber im moment sind
von 1 spannend
also da vorne ich sag mal 25 meter
weiter die beamten schon zweieinhalb
stunden und die sind nicht wirklich
weitergekommen aber ich drücke die
daumen dass hier leute anstehen schon
für foto ventura und british airways im
selben schalter erstmal eingecheckt
werden aber es liegt auch ein bis 70
alles nicht aber auch ein bisschen daran
dass hier keiner mit einer gelben weste
ist und mal so ein bisschen
wir können uns natürlich jetzt mal eben
eine anziehen vielleicht irgendwas
besser das stimmt guten flug danke also
teilweise noch gute laune flughafen
düsseldorf das also die stimmen dort aus
den langen schlangen bei dir du hast
gerade familie glatz dort getroffen und
die hat einmal erzählt was passiert wenn
man nicht viele stunden vor dem
eigentlichen flugtermin schon in der
schlange steht dann dreht man halt
wieder ab schauen wir mal was denn
passiert ist
familie glatz mit gepackten koffern aber
leider ohne flug was passiert ja wir
waren rechtzeitig hier so wie es uns
gesagt worden ist vier uhr öffnet das
das security terminal und da war schon
ganz lange schlange wir haben uns darauf
eingestellt und sind leider nicht mehr
pfleger mitbekommen der weg wo wollen
sie hin und wann wäre gegangen alicante
26 wir hatten kein gepäck mit nur
handgepäck wir mussten also sein
eingecheckt wir mussten nicht zum job
von gepäck also eigentlich sagt man so
ein anderthalb stunden aber wir waren
doch noch mal sicher ja und hat trotzdem
nicht funktioniert er glaubt jetzt
stehen sie mit ihrer frau auf gepackten
koffern und
gegen urlaubstag flöten jetzt geht es
morgen los ja wir haben glück gehabt
dass wir morgen flieger kriegen und dass
wir morgen danach alicante kommen ja
wann müssen sie dann den morgen da sein
damit das gleiche dilemma nicht nochmal
passiert ich denke mal mindestens eine
zwei stunden früher jetzt ist der urlaub
die schönste zeit im jahr man freut sich
eigentlich drauf und jetzt geht einmal
aber trotzdem tat flöten ich meine alles
ist zu hause vorbereitet alles ist in
koffern es hat nicht total ärgerlich
absolut ärgerlich aber wir müssen das
beste draus machen also ich denke mal
wir werden noch an die airline oder an
den flughafen herantreten um zu gucken
was da noch möglich ist anschauen und
ersatz aber hilft ja nichts augen zu und
durch guten flug dankeschön
die rheinische frohnatur die ist da auf
jeden fall nicht abhanden gekommen auch
wenn es natürlich ein mega mega stress
ist für all die reisenden dort michael
janine vielen herzlichen dank an euch an
unserem flughafen reporter die dort die
reisenden begleiten und sich am besten
selber schnell gelbe weste anziehen um
dort die reisenden zu unterstützen danke
euch